ونحييكم الى تفاصيل النقاش الاول حلم
السويد بالانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
الناتو قد يكونوا قريبا كما استنتج
مراقبون القضاء السويدي في خطوه استثنائيه
اقر بالسماح بتسليم مناصر لحزب العمله
الكردستاني الى تركيا وهو الاجراء الذي قد
يلبي شرطا رئيسيا واضعته تركيا للموافقه
على انضمام السويد الى الناتو صحيفه افتون
السويديه اشارات الى ان هذا الاجراء لا
يكمن او لا يمكن العوده عنه بان هذه
الاجراءات الان في ملعب الحكومه اما
بالتسليم او لا واذا قررت الحكومه تسليمه
فسيصبح هذا الرجل اول مؤيد لحزب العمال
الكردستاني تسلمه ستوكهولم الى انقره
وبحسب الصحيفه فان الرجل البالغ من العمر
35 عاما صدر بحقه في تركيا في عام 2014
حكم بالسجن اكثر من اربع سنوات بتهمه
بمخدرات وبعدما حصل على اطلاق سراح مشروط
انتقل فيما بعد الاقامه في السويد لكن
السلطات في ستوكهولما اوقفته في اغسطس
الماضي بناء على طلب من النيابه العامه
التركيه التي تسعى الى اجباره على قضاء
الفتره المتبقيه من عقوبته خلف القضبان
لكن الرجل يقول ان السلطات التركيه
تستهدفه بسبب دعمه لحزب العمال الكردستاني
يذكر مشاهدينا ان تركيا منذ ثلاثه عشر
شهرا تعطل انضمام ستوكهولم الى الناتو
بحجره تساهلها كما تقول مع نشطينا اكراد
تستضيفهم على اراضها
السويد وتركيا وعضويه حلف الناتو السويد
وفنلندا تقدمتا للحصول على عضويه الحلف
بعد اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا في فبراير
من عام 2022 بينما انضمت فنلندا للتحالف
العسكري الغربي في ابريل تم تاجيل محاوله
انضمام السويد بسبب اعتراضات من تركيا
والمجر الخلافات بين تركيا والسويد تعود
لفتره طويله مضت السويد انتقدت سجل تركيا
في مجال حقوق الانسان والتزامها
بالديمقراطيه وتركيا تقول ان السويد تؤوي
اعضاء في جماعات تعتبرها انقر ارهابيه اما
النيتو فيرى ان ستوكهولم اوفت بالتزاماتها
وان على انقره ان تستكمل انضمام الدوله
الاسكندنافيه الى الحلف السويد فرضت
قانونا جديدا لمكافحه الارهاب اعتبره
المتظاهرون الذين خرجوا لشوارع ستوكهولم
مطلع الاسبوع وليد الضغوط التركيه
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من اربيل
الدكتور سربس نبي وسادو الفلسفه السياسيه
في جامعه كويا اهلا بك معنا ومن اسطنبول
الدكتور مهند حافظ
السياسي اهلا بكم ضيوف الكرام اسمحوا لي
ان ابدا من اسطنبول دكتور مهند في خطوه
اعتبرت استثنائيه يقول مراقبون بان السويد
اختارت الاكراد قربانا لتقدمهم لتركيا في
محاوله لتسويه موضوع الناتو هل تتفق اولا
مع هذا الطرح
والموضوع الاهم هل هذه الخطوه ترضي تركيا
وجميع المشاهدين طبعا هنا عده نقاط
تمهيديه يجب ذكرها اولا تركيا ليست لديها
مشكله مع المكون الكردي على الاطلاق في
الحكومه الجديده على سبيل المثال ثلاث
وزراء من الاكراد من المكون الكردي في
تركيا وحتى نائب الرئيس رئيس الجمهوريه من
المكون الكردي المشكله ليست مع الاكراد
المشكله مع من يدعم الارهاب من هم
ارهابيون لبن لباس الكرديه لبسوا لباس
الاسلاميه ايا كان لباسهم تركيا تحاربهم
لذلك هي تحارب داعش والبي كيكه على حد
سواء وربما نشهد لاحقا دعوات تركيه لتاسيس
تنظيم دولي لمحاربه حزب العمال الكردستاني
لانه بسببه الكثير من الملفات تبقى عالقه
والكثير من العلاقات الدوليه ما بين عدد
الدول ولها ارتباطات بهذا الملف سواء
جغرافيا سياسيا دعما ماليا عسكريا ايا كان
هذا الارتباط هذا يؤرق هذه العلاقات ما
بين الدول بناء عليه تسليم شخص او شخصين
او عشره يعني السويد وكان تريد ان تذر
الرامات في العيون صحيح هي خضعت لشروط
التركيه وبدات
المحكمه العليا في ستوكهولم قررت بتقديم
بعض المطلوبين ولكن هذا غير كافي تركيا
لديها وكانت خططها وخطها واضح وصحيح ولم
تتغير ولم تختلف عنهم اذا لم يتم تسليم
جميع المطلوبين الذين يقارب عددهم المائه
شخص كلهم دون استثناء فان الفيتو التركي
سوف يبقى معلقا
ومرفوعا وموجودا على السيف رغبه السويته
انضمامها لحلف الشمال الاطلسي اذا ما
ارتات السويد لاحقا
بانضمامها لحلف الشمال الاطلسي اولى من
دعم اولئك الارهابيين ومن يدعمهم فانها
سوف تسلم والا سوف يبقى الامر ما بين شد
وجذب والامر يعني يتخذ منحا خطيرا في
الملف الاو صحيح ولكن قبل قبل دخول الى
تفاصيل اخرى قبل الدخول الى التفاصيل
الملف الاوكراني حضرتك ترى بان تركيا ليست
لديها مشاكل مع الاكراد او مع الكرد ولكن
لديها مشاكل مع من يؤيد البكيك حزب العمال
الكردستاني دكتور نبي ما رايك في هذا
الكلام خاصه وان من يؤيد طرح ضيفي يقول
كذلك بان الاكراد في داخل التركي يمثلون
تقريبا من 15 الى 20% من اجمالي سكان
تركيا خمس تقريبا سكان تركيا هم من
الاكراد فلماذا تركيا
تحاول ان تقف في مواجهه عنصر مهم اكبر
اقليه فدخل التركي
هذه بدعه بالمناسبه عدد الذين ادخلوا الى
هذه الحكومه هم من المتطبعين بالمجال
السياسي للسلطه التركيه ومتبرئون تماما من
كرديتهم اي لا هويت كرديه لديهم على
الدوام في تاريخ تركيا منذ تاسيس مجلس
المبعوثان حتى اليوم كان الاكثريه في داخل
حتى البرلمان التركي من ذوي اصول كرديه
لكنهم كانوا على الدوام ممن يتنكرون حتى
الاعتراف بهويتهم الكرديه هذا من جانب اول
وجود على في كل الشعوب هناك طبقه اسمحي لي
ارجوك اسمحيلي
بالبرلمان ولكن هل هذا يشمل كذلك وزراء
اردوغان الجدد
نعم نعم يشمل كل هؤلاء تودين باستثناء
محمد شيشك الذي لديه الى حد ما هو
تكنوقراط اما البقيه فالبقيه يعني حقا في
دار لا يحتاج الى تعريف هو من اشد
المعادين للكرد في التاريخ وكذلك الكردي
زازاي من
نائب الرئيس او مساعده رئيس وقس على ذلك
وهناك من ماردين واعداء اعرف احدهم بكل
الاحوال خلينا نعود يعني تركيا
القول بان تركيا ليس لديها عداء مع مع
الكرد خرافه هي فعلا خرافه سياسيه اعداء
تركيا داخل وعداء العقل السياسي التركي
ليس فقط اردوغان وحزب العداله والتنميه
اعداء تاريخي والرهاب المزمن للعقل
السياسي التركي هو وجود المساله الكرديه
حتى ان اللسان حالهم يقول ان لو انه هناك
دوله او كيان كردي على القمر او المريخ
سنحاربه هذا ليس الموضوع الذي نستطيع
نقاشه الان لكن بالعوده الى الموضوع
الاساسي موضوع نقاشنا هذه الليله تركيا
اولا ليس لديها موقف مبدا ايزا قضيه
الارهاب هي من اشد من رات تداعش وبوسعي ان
اسوق الان اسماء دواعش حتى داخل تركيا
وتحت المناطق التي في المناطق التي تحت
نفوذ الجيش التركي ومعظم قاده داعش قتلوا
على مقرب من قواعد عسكريه تركيه هذه ايضا
واضحه السويد لم تخضع قطعا
السويد لم تخطع لم تخضع لقطعا لابتزاز
تركيا لانها في الوقت نفسه رفض التسليم
سياسي ناشط سياسي كردي اخر
هؤلاء هذا الذي سلم عمر اتلاي لديه قضيه
جنائيه وهناك اتفاقات دوليه بشان تبادل
الذين عليهم احكام جنائيه وليس
نشطاء السياسي السؤال الذي ينبغي طرحه في
هذا السياق هل فعلا قضيه حزب العمال
الكردستاني هو الذي يحول دون تدخل ويشكل
جوهره اعتراض تركيا
على قبول السويت في الناتو باعتقادي لا
قطعا القضيه ليست قضيه حزب العمال
بالاساس نشطه حزب العمال ومراكزهم في
بروكسل عاصمه الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي باريس
وهناك محزمه
تركي نحن لما نقرا التصريحات السياسيه
التركيه
ما تقوله تركيا لنوضح للجمهور
خلينا نفكك هذه المزاعم وهذه مساله في
غايه الاهميه لان نفس الزريعه كان كانت
تقال بحق فنلندا لكنها قبلت مقابل طائرات
15 القضيه هناك تركيا طلبت من السويد
تسليمها معارضينهم من اشد خصوم حزب العمال
الكردستاني لكنهم ايضا معارضون لاردوغان
ولحزب اردوغان ولسياسه اردوغان اردوغان
علينا دائما ان نضع في اعتبارنا اردوغان
لديه ولع سياسي
استعراض ويريد ان يبرهن لجمهوره لجمهور ان
كلمته كلمته هي النافذه ولا راد لها في
الشان الدولي وعاده كانت هياذيته المعهوده
يختار القضايا الصغيره ليحقق انتصارا
مضمونا فيها ثم يقدمها للجمهور على ان
انتصارات خارقه طيب سلموا واحد محكوم
بالاحتيال او بتجاره المخدرات اسمع لي غدا
ماذا سيقول جمهور امام غوغائه رجب طيب
اردوغان سيعتبره نصرا قوميا خارقا هذا ما
يريده اردوغان من كل القصه
على مجموعه النقاط التي اتيت عليها دكتور
نبي لو سمحت لانك اتيت على مجموعه من
النقاط وضيفك ان يستمع وكان يعارض مجموعه
هذه النقاط ويود التعليق كذلك نترك لها
الكلمه حتى يعلق تفضل دكتور اوغلو
طبعا انا ادرك ليس فقط ضيفك الكثير ممن هم
متالمين من انتصار الرئيس اردوغان
للمنصب الرئاسه في تركيا ولهذه القوه
التركيه الدوليه هذا الامر يعني اصبح
واضحا نتفهم هذا الالم الذي يتالمونه يقول
لك
ابدا من حيث انتهى ان الذي تطالبهم بهم
تركياهم معارضون لحزب العمال كردستان هذا
غير صحيح ليس لانه معرضون للرئيس اردوغان
هنا هنا في داخل يظهر على اخر نقطه مش هذه
اخر بها قال اردوغان انتهازي
تفضل نعم نعم نعم هذا كله رد على هذه
النقطه يقول لك
فنلندا لم ترضخ للشروط لفنلندا لا تحوي
اولئك الارهابيين هذه تحويهم اسود الفرق
كبير ما بين الملف الفنلندي والملف
السويدي كانت عاقله عندما
اخذت قرارها وانفصمت اكتب اكتب
اخذت قرارها وانفصلت عن استويت في ملف
انضمام
لاحلف الشمال الاطلسي ثانيا يقول لك ان
تركيا تعارض اي كيان كردي وتحاربه ليست
ليس اقليم كردستان العراق الذي هو موجود
فيه لديه افضل العلاقات مع الجانب التركي
فقط لنتحدث خلينا من العراق خلينا في
تركيا في تركيا مثلا لما يكون فقط على
النقطه حضرتك لانك تقول بان حكومه اردوغان
علاقتها ممتازه مع الاكراد سيقول لك بعضهم
في ديار بكر مثلا اللغه المستخدمه هي
اللغه الكرديه ولكن لا شيء يوحي بهويه
المنطقه كل اللافتات بالتركي ممنوع
الدراسه بالكردي هناك تعلم بانه هناك
الازمه ابتدات منذ الثمانينات وهناك مطالب
كرديه بتحقيق حقوق ليس فقط سياسيه وانما
كذلك ثقافيه
صحيح وكانت هناك دعوات تركيه لحل الملف
ولكن زعيمهم صلاح الدين اضع الفرصه على
الاكراد من خلال هذا التصالح هذا اولا
ثانيا هنا الفارق يقول لك ان هؤلاء
الوزراء وهؤلاء النواب قد تخلوا عن
كرديتهم هذا هو الفارق الجوهري من ان تكون
تركيا كرديا او ان تكون اولا كرديا تركيا
الانتماء للوطن هو الاساس هو ليس للقوميه
القوميات كثيره
والاقليات كثيره والاثنيات كثيره الانتماء
للوطن هو الاساس هو ليس الانتماء للقوميه
هذا ثانيا
ثالثا يقول لك تركيا لم تحارب داعش وتدعم
داعش يا رجل زعيم تنظيم داعش في سوريا
تركيا هي من حيدته هي من قتلتهم العمليات
العسكريه والامنيه والاستخباراتيه سواء في
داخل التركي او في او في سوريا او في
سوريا هي من قبل القوات التركيه هذا
الواقع الذي يريد انه يظهر به على ان
تركيا محاربه للمكون الكردي انا اعيد
واكرر ان تركيا من خلال هؤلاء الوزراء عن
تركيا ليست لديها مشكله مع المكون الكردي
على الاطلاق هناك تي ار تي كردي يعني هناك
لغه قناه ناطقه باللغه الكرديه على مدار
24 ساعه قناه تي ار تي هناك الكردي وهناك
التركي وهناك عربي
هذا الكلام طيب وانت تتحدث فقط دكتور نبي
يقول مش صحيح ما الذي ورد غير دقيق دكتور
طب خليه يعلق اولا قناه تي ار تي اتحداه
ان يثبت لي لفظ اقليم كردستان ورد مره
واحده على على فضائيه او في نشره وكاله
اناضول يقولون
عراقي
الشمالي او اقليم الشمال العراق تمام شمال
العراق اقليم شمال العراق
الكردي
لا تقاطعني
غصبا عنك وعن اردوغان واللي خلف اردوغان
طيب
النقطه الثانيه قبل ايام ماتت فنانه كرديه
في سجون تركيا قبل ايام ماتت فنانه كرديه
في سجون تركيا
بمرض سرطان نتيجه الغناء منظمات حقوق
الانسان التي طالبت وكانت تعاني من مرض
مزمن وماتت بالنهايه نتيجه اضراب عن
الطعام بوسعي ذكر عشرات الامثله عن اعتقال
واغلاق صحف الان صحف الكرديه معظمه الا من
رغب للترويج لخطاب الاسلام السياسي من
الكردي المحافظين المحسوبين على حزب
العداله والتنميه يا سيدتي تركيا لم تحارب
داعش العالم كله يعلم ان قاده داعش قتلوا
امراء داعش قتلوا على مقربه ودخل الاراضي
التي تحت سيطره الجيش التركي نحن لا نتالم
اردوغان مثله مثل الهدهد الاخر كالجدار
اوغلو سيان كلاهما طورانيان كلاهما
دكتور اوغلو فقط حتى لا ندخل في تفاصيل
الاسماك كذلك والشخصيات لانه الموضوع يعني
نصف ساعه لا تكفي لشرحه لتقديم كذلك مختلف
التحليلات ولكن كيف سيكون المستقبل نحن
انطلقنا من جزئيه تسليم السويد لشخص
محكوم عليه بالسجن ولكن يقال بانه لانه
يناصر البيكيكي فقامت
بعد حكم قضائي من اعلى محكمه قضائيه في
السويد قررت انها تسلمه لتركيا وكانت هناك
وكان هناك جدل كبير بخصوص امكانيه ان ترضى
تركيا تقول حضرتك بان هذا الموضوع لا يرضي
تركيا ولكن هذا الموضوع كيف سيكون تاثيره
على علاقه تركيا باقراضها في الداخل
اكرادها نتحدث على خمس اجمالي سكانها ليس
فقط من يؤيد الدكتور اوغلو
هنا لا نتحدث عن المكون الكردي على
الاطلاق هنا نتحدث ان هؤلاء اتراك يعني
الدوله التركيه والشعب التركي كان اقوى قد
اعطى كلمته وقياده هذه البلاد الداخليه
وخارجيا من خلال صناديق الاقتراع الاسلوب
الديمقراطي الدولي للرئيس اردوغان وهذا
الرئيس اردوغان وحكومته يصرون على هذا
الموقف هذا يعني موافقه ضمنيه لكل
المكونات الكردي منها والعربي منها
الاديان كلها توافق على ما يقوم به الرئيس
اردوغان من خلال هذه السياسه والا لكانوا
قد حاسبوه في صناديق الاقتراع يعني منذ
سنوات وليس ان يمشي في هذا الخط كانوا
يريدون بالفعل ان يقومون بتغييره لكان
الجواب في صناديق هذا اولا ثانيا استاذه
ريم الامر ليس منوطا فقط في السويد هناك
بعد في غايه الاهميه وهو الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ما لم تقم واشنطن بدور ايجابي
في تقارب الوجهات النظر او وضغط على
السويد
يتوجه اليها عدد كبير من الاكراد تفضل
صحيح صحيح ولكن ما دام هناك يعني انت
تقولين ان السويد لماذا لانها تدعم وتفتح
الطريق
لحزب العمال الكردستاني لماذا غير دول لا
تستقبلهم لماذا تدعمهم سياسيا ماليا يعني
الامر كان
امتعاد ولكن
مظاهرات مظاهرات ضد قرار المحكمه هذا يعني
ليس بالموضوع الجديد موضوع منذ عقود وسويت
تفتح ابوابها للاجئين وهنا سؤال ساختم معك
يا دكتور
صحيح
ولكن دكتور نبي كيف سيؤثر هذا الموضوع على
داخل السويدي كيف سيؤثر هذا الموضوع على
الاكراد وهم بالالاف داخل السويد
هناك ليس في السويد ثقل الاساسي لحزب
العمال الكردستاني في المانيا حليفه
الاولى لتركيا وفي فرنسا وفي بروكسيل
الكرد الموجودين في في مؤيدي حزب العمال
حزب العمال القادر قادر على اخراج عشرات
الالاف في ساحات الاوروبيه وحزب كبير
وبالتالي من المتعذر ان تطالب اي دوله
بتسليم عشرات الالاف من مناصري حزب العمال
الى لكن السويد لحد الان لم تسلم لم تخضع
للابتزاز
السويد لحد الان لا معايير حقوق الانسان
كما نعلم ومعظم معارضي اردوغان ورؤساء
تحرير الصحف
ونشطاء السياسيين في السويد من الصعب على
الدوله السويديه الا اذا كان هناك حكم
قضائي واحد حكم القضائي لا يخضع لاي
ابتزاز سياسي في السويد كما نعلم ما حدث
اليوم امس هو ان احدهم عليه امرا حكما
جنائيا وهناك اتفاقيات دوليه يعني جرائم
الجنائيه هي غير الجرائم السياسيه الناشط
السياسي الاخر لم يتم تسليمه الى الدوله
التركيه ولا يمكن للسويد اي حكومه
السويديه باعتقاده اذا خضعت او بعد كل شيء
مقابل ابتزازات الرئيس التركي ستسقط من
الصالح تحقيق هذا الامر ثم انه من الصعب
تسليم الالاف من نشطاء حزب العمال وغير
هناك احزاب كرديه غير حزب العمال غير حزب
العمال الكردستاني احزاب كرديه لم تحمل
مسدسا واحدا اردوغان يطالب بتسليم نشطاء
السياسيين منهم وهذا الكلام موجود ضمن
الاسماء القائمه التي يجهلها ضيفك في
اسطنبول وطالب باسماء من هو يحمل الجنسيه
السويديه منذ اكثر من 20 سنه من المحادثه
اذا كان اردوغان يريد ابتزاز ولايات
المتحده ومجموعه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
القضيه ليست قضيه حزب عمال كونوا على ثقه
بان القضيه هو ابتزاز سياسي وتركيا قلقه
جدا من انضمام السويد لانه ستفقد اهميتها
التي اكتسبتها بعد مشروع ترومان هذا هو
جوه
طرحته اضطريتني ان اعود مجرد للدكتور
اوغلو باختصار شديد في كلمه تعليقك على
يعني تركيا لا تفتز تركيا تضع شروطها
تركيا دوله قويه دوله لها ثقلها بالرغم من
كل من يكرهها ويكره رئيسها لها ثقلها ولها
دورها الاساسي ما بين شرق والغرب تركيا
عندما تفرد شروطا فانها تستمر حتى النهايه
ما لم تسلم السويد المطلوبين فلا دخول
لحلف شمال الاطلس شكرا جزيلا لك من
اسطنبول دكتور مهند حافظ اوغلو الباحث
السياسي ومن اربيل شكر موصول كذلك لك ضيفي
الدكتور
الفلسفه السياسيه في جامعه كوريا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات